hello and welcome to a special edition
of discover Germany the Travel Guide on
DW today we want to take a look at the
history of Germany divided and Germany
United first we are off to Leipzig it
was here in 1989 that the peaceful
revolution began and set in motion
events that led to German unity on a
city tour we explore scenes of this time
of historic change
Leipzig a city on the move and busier
than ever since reunification the
historical city centre has been restored
the world-famous given to us the trade
fair complex there are plenty of reasons
to visit Leipzig and lots of history the
city held its breath in the autumn of
1989 the nikolaikirche was the beating
heart of the Monday marches that
ultimately culminated in the end of the
communist regime and the reunification
of the country the pivotal role played
by the church is recounted in Calvin
Shui Blas guided tour taking in key
local sights of the peaceful revolution
this church didn't become famous because
of its architecture in 1982 it began
holding special Monday prayers over the
next few years the prayers attracted a
growing number of people who were
opposed to how society was developing in
what was then East Germany the result
was the Monday demonstrations Calvin
table was a witness to history she took
part in the protests the forum of
contemporary history gives visitors a
comprehensive picture of Germany during
the Cold War it shows how the one-party
communist government and the East came
into being the museum illustrates what
life was like for East Germans from
communist style competition and Industry
to a typical families living room
1989 marked the beginning at the end as
the party top brass celebrated the
state's 40th birthday the system was
already crumbling beneath them the
Monday demonstrations began in September
by October the 9th the number of
protesters was overwhelming the
authorities considered using physical
force there were seven or eight thousand
armed men in and around the center of
live see between seventy and a hundred
thousand protesters were expected the
regular police and Stasi forces would
have been able to tackle thirty to forty
thousand but not seventy or eighty
thousand the demonstrators chanted no
violence it was dangerous to film the
activities chawla takes her tour to the
place where two activists shot illegal
footage this church is precisely the
place where the first film was shot
about Monday protests the material was
then passed on to a journalist from West
Germany this journalist smuggled this
little reel of film to the West in his
underwear in a very discrete place and
he got through the fear was that the
secret police the Stasi would catch him
and keep the recording the Rhondda
occurred around corner is the former
Leipzig headquarters of the Stasi it was
occupied by residents in December 1989
to prevent the authorities destroying
more incriminated files by the time they
arrived however many documents were
already pop the building now houses a
museum about the Stasi among the
exhibits an old phone tapping device and
a machine for opening letters the museum
reveals the sinister workings of East
Germany's infamous secret police dubious
holitzer was one of the civilian
activists I know
in the very first night we found a meter
high pile of sacks filled with mail
we're in a post office or at the stasi
and that's when I realized just what the
Stasi was and my gut reaction was that
it must be definitely dissolved the
stassi's tasks included monitoring and
intimidating its own citizens but it did
not ultimately use mass physical force
against demonstrators Augustus Platz was
the epicenter of the protests a peaceful
revolution with not a single life lost
that's something we can be absolutely
happy about and grateful for the
opportunity to experience it how often
do you experience something like that
taking a tour with Calvin Troy blur is
just one of the many options in Leipzig
for rediscovering modern German history
our next stop is Berlin where visitors
to the capital can see traces of the
time when East and West Germany were two
separate countries from 1961 until 1989
the Berlin Wall divided the city we
visit a few sites from that period
for visitors from around the world the
Brandenburg Gate is the symbol of the
once divided city since German
reunification Berlin has seen a lot of
change many traces of its division have
been eradicated people retracing this
history go to checkpoint charlie
potsdamer platz
all the eastside gallery were artists
have painted the longest remaining
section of the berlin wall but there are
places all over the city that still show
traces of the wall that once surrounded
West Berlin to explore some of them on
foot the Berlin Wall memorial is a good
place to start in some spots the wall
dissected residential districts like
here on Bernauer Strasse the memorial
includes original border fortifications
which give visitors a chance to see the
physical means used by East Germany to
keep its citizens from escaping these
are elements that these elements were
part of what was called the electrical
arm fence it was embedded 40 centimeters
in the ground to stop people from
tunneling their way out if touched it
sent an alarm signal notifying the
border guards without the escapees
knowledge the window of remembrance
commemorates the people who were shot
dead at the border all those who died
accidentally
they include children who fell into the
water while playing since parts along
the banks of the river spray were border
areas no one was able to fish them out
six children lost their lives here
because no one rescued them neither the
border guards nor passers-by nor even
their parents who were close by
bells ring-out at the Chapel of
reconciliation in remembrance of another
church of the same name which once stood
on the site it was demolished by the
East German regime in 1985 a banner
schlosser you can see exactly where the
wall once stood one of the few remnants
that remained standing if you see this
double row of paving stones in Berlin
you'll know that's where the wall once
stood and if you don't know which side
is East and which is West look for the
metal plate you can only read it if
you're standing on the west side from
this spot you can see a border
fortification as it would have looked in
the time of the wall
you can't go inside but from above it it
becomes clear that there was a broad
strip of no-man's land between the front
concrete wall and the second wall behind
it just splitting a city in the
splitting of people in is really really
horrible to see but obviously it's
really good to as a European to
understand what happened and to know
that really we should try and avoid that
again a 20-minute walk away we come to
the watchtower ancilla fossa nowadays
it's surrounded by new buildings while
Berlin was divided East German soldiers
stood watch over the border on the
berlin spandau canal 73 year-old Jurgen
- gives tours of the watchtower he knows
every detail of the tower were 12 border
guards were always on duty to ensure no
one escaped to West Berlin one troops
left four were on standby and four were
out on patrol Jurgen latrine doesn't
just explain how the wall used to look
here he also tells visitors about his
brother Gundel Edwin was the first
person to be shot dead at the wall the
watchtower is a memorial to him it's
thanks to Jurgen that the tower is still
standing
it had faced a militia then the court
decided the tash would neither be torn
down nor moved and that was the
incentive for us to convert it into a
memorial not only for my brother whose
name it bears but also all other Berlin
victims a 15-minute walk from the
watchtower is the sin Hedwig cemetery a
fence now stands where the wall once ran
no concessions were made not even four
graves Heine clonic shows the scars the
wall left there are no longer tombs to
be seen just an empty lon when the wall
was built the graves were simply
moved a plaque serves as a reminder
doesn't die often our fansite there's a
list of names of those who lie under the
border strip one was the architect ansed
van inna who after shingo significantly
influenced the cityscape but his grave
has been lost forever
our doesn't cop is falafel wrong a third
of the cemetery had to make way for the
wall only a few tombstones could be
saved and relocated another silent
reminder of the decades when Berlin was
divided by a wall
staying in Berlin we now visit some of
the spots where the wall once stood with
Canadian tourists Jeremy hexam the war
was a hundred and sixty kilometers in
length so Jeremy decided to focus on
sites in the city centre
my name is Jeremy hexam I am from
Calgary Alberta Canada where I am doing
my PhD in political communications at
the University of Calgary today we're
going to look at the history of the the
sites of the Berlin Wall which fell
November 9th 1989
a good part of the Berlin Wall is
actually still marked so we're going to
go on our trip to the pulling the Berlin
Wall trail
it just it's amazing how society a group
of people government could do that to
people it's just unreal I'm here at the
famous checkpoint charlie just down the
street over there
it's a checkpoint charlie mera museum I
want to go in there because it should
have displaced that show how people
escaped through over and under the
Berlin wall as well as what life was
like and I'm really interested in just
what it was like living with the Berlin
Wall in the middle of a divided city
this museum is incredibly interesting
not only does it give the history of
checkpoint charlie and the way people
escaped which I thought that's all it
would have it gave the history of the
Berlin wall and a lot of the information
about the GDR
behind me is one of your last original
guard towers still standing in Berlin
the reason I wanted to come to this top
tower was simply because it's last one
standing and the chance to go up and
actually see what it looked like and to
see what the guards would have looked
like when they were on Patrol I see a
lot of grassy field
I see trees but it gets back in the DDR
days what I see is death strip and if
anyone tried to escape or move over
there or I could death somebody would
open fire
so far in this trip I've been looking at
the Berlin Wall and issues related to
the Berlin Wall but what was like to
live in East Germany I have several
friends who grew up in the East and
they've tried to explain it to me but
I've never got a chance to actually
understand it at least here at the DVR
Museum I'm gonna see what life was like
in East Germany so let's go in
in my opinion the fall of the Berlin
Wall was one of the greatest events of
the 20th century if I had a time machine
I would love I would do anything to go
back to be in Berlin on November 9th
1989 this is a fabulous trip and thank
you for coming with me on my Berlin Wall
DDR roadtrip hopefully we'll see you in
Berlin really soon
our next destination is Aizen Hooton
stud it was designed as a model
socialist city with housing factories
and parks laid out according to plan
today
tours give visitors a chance to learn a
little about what life was like in the
old East Germany
in Eisen Hooton stat the architecture
itself is a monument to history in the
model socialist city industrial workers
would live in spacious green housing
estates rather than dark and crowded
urban tenements
your advisor knows that it's the stories
and history behind the architecture that
makes it so interesting but sufficient
Amma what draws people here today is the
relationship between the socialist
ideals of the former East Germany and
the architecture they created after all
isin Hooten stock doesn't have anything
spectacular like colognes Cathedral or
that's finger Palace in Dresden in Eisen
Hooten start the most spectacular site
is the steel works visible halfway
across the city the local museum
documents the city as it was envisioned
nearly 60 years ago an old architectural
map in the grand old city's most
familiar to tourists a central boulevard
like this one ends at the palace gate
but here it's the gate of the factory
hisin Hooten scott was originally known
as a challenge dot but was renamed in
1961 old video recordings document the
pride of place once held by the model
city the digger excavates fresh soil
only recently covered by mighty pine
trees some for a rolling mill the rest
for a new power plant and here a new
smelting furnace the fifth one
the factory was called Eisen Hooten
combi not asked ironworks combine East
for short EK o today it's owned by
ArcelorMittal a global steel company
visitors can take a look behind the
scenes and watch molten iron being
poured into special molds it's heated to
over 1,200 degrees Celsius and then
processed into hot rolled coils the
steel works now employs about 2,500
people only a fraction of what it was in
the former East Germany but the factory
still shapes the city's identity it's an
impressive operation for the visitors to
karate was fascinating I've never seen
anything like it before I didn't want to
leave next it's time to visit the city's
documentation center the museum was
founded in a building that once housed a
daycare center today the collection
holds over 100,000 artifacts from the
former East Germany cleaning supplies
soup packets stockings just a few of the
many consumer goods on display but the
point isn't to evoke a fuzzy haze of
nostalgia the exhibition wants to bring
viewers to a better understanding of
life in the former East Germany some
displays are on the whimsical side like
this board depicting production targets
with rubber bands others capture how
socialist ideology was imprinted onto
the fabric of everyday life a visit to
Eisen Hooton shot offers many
opportunities to learn about the history
of the former East Germany and one of
the best ways to understand it is on a
walking tour after all the very city is
a living monument to history
and finally let's go for a walk in the
woods the German Greenbelt is a unique
Nature Reserve that was developed along
the former heavily guarded border that
ran through Germany as you walk along
the Greenbelt who may come across
remnants of the old fortifications we
tagged along on a tour that begins in
Bavaria
Michalka snare takes day-trippers up to
a good vantage point over the former
no-man's land between West and East
Germany the site is marked by a peace
crucifix the border security was set up
on the hill this was better than having
it on the slopes they're standing
outside Nord Hofmann in Bavaria right on
the border with the state of Turing it
in what used to be East Germany it's an
area of natural beauty this is the West
it wasn't always this easy to cross the
stream that used to be a hot border in a
cold war is now a puddle jump how was it
back then did the fence go right through
to the water the fence was up on the
hill there were little tracks along the
stream on the left and right where the
border guards would patrol we follow
that former Border Patrol path on the
eastern side it's an area of thick
forest it's difficult to negotiate and
it's a world away from how people might
imagine the Iron Curtain
coming up is an original East German
border marker most of the stones are now
overgrown and hard to find some ended up
in gardens as souvenirs
heritage signs mark the area where
Germany and Europe was divided for
almost four decades the border fence and
watchtowers now exist only in
photographs the Local History Museum in
north Albin tells the story of how the
inner German border eventually fell away
in November 1989 our heritage hike takes
in almost 10 kilometers of the former
border zone in total the strip lines its
way through 1,400 kilometers of central
and northern Germany this hill used to
be occupied by border security
installations and it was off-limits to
the public that seclusion allowed
special biotopes to evolve home to rare
plants and animals but how did things
look back during the Cold War these were
the first border fences erected here
they have the simple barbed-wire fence
and here you can see the first obstacles
to prevent cars breaking through our
tour is almost over so how about some
liquid refreshment unrecovered
the bar in this case is a cave it's
self-service with passing hikers
expected to pay voluntarily an
expression of their boundless and
borderless honesty plus there's no
watchtowers or guards to patrol their
activities that's all for this edition
of discovered a Meany the Travel Guide
on DW thanks for watching until next
time
you